I don't like to do this I don't like to
out somebody on the team for poor
performance it's not my style I don't
put down I build up no you don't talk to
the opposite all you do is absolutely
it's my entire time
you know what I was thinking of the
Obamas oh you thought you were there and
then I remembered no I'm talking about
me your slogan is when when they go high
you go low yeah no My slogan is I don't
care where they go I go low and if they
go very low I go even lower yeah I'm low
all the time wherever they go I hunt
them down and kill them yeah and and I
attack from underneath because I'm so
far below them
um I'm disappointed because we owe a lot
of uh credit
to this gentleman Eduardo who's done a
wonderful job designing this studio uh
he's our engineer you can hear him on
the podcast sometimes and he's always on
it yeah and we were just ready to start
recording when it was revealed to me
he's got several monitors and I thought
he was checking sound levels checking
you know making sure that the recording
is happening you know he's monitoring
the NORAD missile defense system keeping
us safe he's got three different screens
uh if you include uh his cell phone
which is also propped up we just took a
peek he's watching soccer two games he's
watching two games simultaneously and
Eduardo did someone just score you got
really excited I didn't listen to a word
Conan just said
this is the guy monitoring the Audio I
just know it works because I heard
something but uh yeah Mexico's playing
right now this is your team this is my
one of my two teams us go USA go Mexico
and if they score another goal they
advance to the next round which they
have done since 1962. okay so what is
the score right now it's two nil two nil
and who are they playing Mexico's
playing against Saudi Arabia right now
their game is also contingent on
Argentina and Poland right potentially
yes so if if Argentina can beat Poland
by three goals then Mexico also gets in
that way and that score is currently 2-0
Argentina oh geez so in either game I
would I want to watch that's right the
game
shout out shout out to blaze for ratting
me out while I was watching these games
and he didn't rat you out blay is you
know uh part of the crew that has to
keep this plane Aloft and he saw uh
someone behaving terribly in the cockpit
is this plane a loft
everyone's kind of you know during the
US game yesterday which was also equally
as important we decided to push back
recording uh of any podcast or anything
like that but during Mexico's game
we were like nope we could keep going
but wait a minute wait a minute In
fairness Right In fairness I want to be
I want to be fair here had I known
Eduardo that's true had I known that
this game was happening and this was
important to you I'm not as Avid a
soccer fan as most people believe
but Eduardo if I had known I would have
said your job's your job and [ __ ] soccer
I'm sorry
I see but I just didn't know so I didn't
get to fair enough no I I feel badly you
are allowed to keep watching the game
and will you update us if anything
happens we'll update you there's like
three minutes left so Eduardo I have to
hand it to you my hats off to you though
you are as corrupt as FIFA in what
you're doing but I I this is the only
sporting event I watch in my entire life
once every four years so I'm with you
thank you oh you follow soccer as well I
do I used to play or if we or as we like
to call it football we do yeah a
football is that right yeah that's
correct football yes would you have been
able to tell if Eduardo like if you
didn't know that he had the game you
wouldn't have been able to tell no he
wasn't I could tell because Eduardo
regularly when he's not paying attention
to soccer he has a couple of dials he
uses that gives me more of a manly voice
and
um they're they're the testosterone
knobs and uh he so I I actually sound
like someone who could still have
children
um instead of uh you know pretty much
turned into Georgia O'Keeffe now uh very
old
how cool is this wow yeah
um but anyway was that it that was it
that was the voice
that's that's not more manly manly
that's me uh just as a feminate but
trapped in a well
yeah help me help me can someone please
lower down the soccer scores
I don't get reception down here
oh
um
I I believe people should stand up for
themselves if you would come to me
Eduardo seriously and said I really want
to watch this game we would have made an
adjustment what else do I have to do I
don't have young kids like Sona and Matt
it doesn't matter Saudi Arabia escort
Mexico
[Music]
why are you laughing because if you
can't laugh at your misery I don't know
what else to do oh he is tearing up I'm
sorry wait this sucks what was the final
score uh it's about to be 2-1 there's a
minute left but either way Mexico now
has to score two goals oh [ __ ] and
that's not gonna happen so
I'm sorry about that or continue podcast
you know what oh man I don't want to do
this well no as miserable as you are
right now just think of if I had
forbidden you to watch it you'd have a
few more moments of happiness but now in
real time we hear your misery and that's
I believe that was Karma if I wouldn't
have been watching I would have never
had the Heartbreak you did this you know
what I have to say I do this too if I'm
watching uh if my football team is down
and they've just been playing terribly I
will leave the room and I say I'm gonna
give them time to sort this out away
from me I'm curious and I'll go and take
a walk or something and then come back
and often
the fortunes have been reversed in my
absence I just have a quick question I
want to travel back on something here
you were going to give Eduardo off if he
simply would have asked for it so if
Sona and I have something that deeply
matters to us as children describe
deeply matters as a new Star Wars TV
show
there's always a new Star Wars TV show
great so this applies we can just no I
mean listen within reason I don't like
to think of myself as the boss I I'm
uncomfortable in that position I like to
think of myself as the absolute dictator
and so uh yeah I don't know of course of
course I want you guys to be happy
you're integral to the whole process so
on the air I'm going to say yes if you
ever need to move the schedule please
move it now it's on record it's on
record no but you don't know the tones
of his voice well I'm just gonna edit
whatever comes after this oh no but that
that tone and the way he said that but I
saw I'm very good at pretending I have
other people do my dirty work for me so
I'll have Adam sacks drop the hammer or
Jeff Ross and then I'll oh I had no idea
I had no idea yeah yeah Oh I thought I I
was fine with you doing whatever you
wanted to see was it start Trek next
it's soccer and it's Star Wars okay well
isn't there a Star Wars where they visit
Star Trek no there should be
what are you doing I'm just saying Luke
Skywalker's there and then Spock is like
live long and prosper oh God that's a
that makes everybody happy that's a
money-making machine everyone upset okay
listen now I know your plan and I know
if Adam comes and puts the hammer down
that I'll know it's you yeah but do you
yes I'm pretty good at sometimes
pretending to be a good guy yeah it's
all pretend it's all pretend
well listen Eduardo I I do I'm sorry uh
for your loss I know that's
disappointing but all you have to do is
wait four years
and maybe you'll have a little bit of
good news